[Musique]
280 millions
280 millions c'est le nombre de
personnes qui souffrent de dépression en
31 millions c'est le nombre de personnes
qui souffraient de troublant sur 2019 et
je dis 2019 parce que c'était avant la
pandémie avec la pandémie ce chiffre a
augmenté depuis de 25%
des statistiques celui qui n'a jamais
été soumis à des problématiques de santé
mentale qui me lance la première pierre
surtout attendez attendez que vous
explique que je vous parle un petit peu
de la santé mentale de la préparation
mentale et comment on peut renforcer son
mental ensuite pourrais-je jeter des
bières pas sur moi
alors oui j'ai fait une dépression je
vous ai pas le tableau
trader sur les marchés financiers belle
voiture bel appartement marié des
enfants travail pour une institution
internationale privilège diplomatique
voyage ma vie est parfaite
vu de l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
je suis dans une souffrance
inexprimable
tout simplement
inexprime et d'autant plus inexprimable
que dans nos sociétés il est
complètement indécent lorsqu'on a un peu
lorsqu'on a un peu mieux l'outil que
quelqu'un il est complètement
inapproprié de se sentir mal de souffrir
alors on souffre en silence
tu veux dire quoi alors j'ai pris ça
pour un compliment et je suis allé
souffrir un peu plus loin et puis j'ai
eu aussi des amis toujours très proches
qui m'ont dit mais pour affaire de crise
mais pourquoi tu fais ça
arrête ça t'apporte quoi tu gagnes quoi
à faire ça
je voulais une classe le glacier était
fermé je me suis dit une crise
d'angoisse et bien ça va faire passer
la souffrance ce qu'on endure c'est réel
on est on invente pas
alors moi j'ai tout fait parce que quand
je fais les choses à me faire les choses
bien tout de suite
premium crise d'angoisse crise de larmes
crise de panique pensée suicidaire à
lucination addiction j'ai tout fait sauf
que j'ai oublié j'ai tout fait et il y a
long processus de guérison s'est entamé
parce qu'il faut avoir le courage pour
guérir faut avoir le courage de regarder
ses blessures et pouvoir avoir le
courage d'être vulnérable
alors deux fois par semaine une fois
chez le psychologue une fois chez le
psychiatre
anxiolytique antidépresseurs et puis
j'en suis arrivé à un point où avant de
sortir je Tamponnais ma cuisse et sur le
tampon il y avait marqué validé checker
par moi et moi-même parce que vous avez
besoin d'un rappel tous les jours je ne
vais pas chercher la validation de
quelqu'un parce que quand on a
l'impression qu'on que ce qu'on est
n'est pas suffisant qu'on n'est pas
assez bien alors on essaye d'en avoir
plus toujours plus et pour certains ça
va être plus d'alcool plus de nourriture
plus de femmes plus de shopping plus de
travail il nous en faut toujours plus on
a toujours des bonnes excuses pour
justifier ça en réalité c'est parce
qu'on n'est pas assez nous-même on
trouve qu'on n'est pas assez suffisant
alors la santé mentale c'est important
et donc les personnes que je reçois je
leur dis
presque systématiquement ce que vous ne
me raconter là c'est pourquoi vous avez
un peu honte
de ce que vous pensez de ce que vous
avez traversé je leur dis on risque de
vous décevoir en fait vous êtes pas
spécial ou bien je l'ai vécu dans ma
chair ou j'ai reçu des personnes qui
l'ont vécu s'il y a des spécialistes qui
sont là pour vous aider c'est parce que
vous n'êtes pas la seule personne dans
le cas donc je voudrais vous dire aussi
quel que soit ce que vous traversez quel
que soit ce que vous traversez vous
n'êtes jamais la seule personne dans ce
cas et ce n'est jamais pour toujours
c'est difficile quand on est dans le
goût de se dire qu'un jour peut-être il
y aura de la lumière c'est difficile
mais ce n'est pas pour toujours et ce
n'est pas que vous
alors la santé mentale dont on veut
faire un tabou sous nos yeux ce n'est
pas juste les fous qui sont à la ville
ce n'est pas non plus juste les
personnes qui ont des maladies qui
doivent prendre des médicaments comme ça
a été mon cas
la définition de l'OMS la santé mentale
c'est un état de bien-être qui permet
d'exploiter son potentiel
un état de bien-être qui permet
d'exploiter son potentiel alors
maintenant j'ai envie de vous demander
ce qui voulait me jeter des pierres là
êtes-vous convaincu aujourd'hui tous
dans cette salle que vous êtes en pleine
exploitation de tout votre potentiel
pouvez-vous affirmer que vous êtes dans
un état de bien-être immense sinon il
faudrait qu'on fasse qu'on prenne soin
de notre santé mentale
lorsque j'ai un athlète compétiteur un
athlète de haut niveau qui vient me voir
pour me dire je veux un mental de
champion pour mes prochaines
compétitions ça veut dire qu'il y a un
mental particulier pour être un champion
quand j'ai un dirigeant quand j'ai un
entrepreneur qui vient me dire je veux
le mental d'acier un mental à toute
épreuve pour l'Empire que je veux créer
c'est à dire qu'il y a un mental
particulier pour atteindre ses objectifs
quand les médecins eux-mêmes m'envoient
leur passion ça veut dire que même pour
être dans une bonne santé physique il y
a un mental particulier
la santé mentale c'est la capacité à
savoir est-ce que le mental que j'ai
aujourd'hui est aligné avec les
objectifs que je veux atteindre
et si c'est pas le cas prenons soin de
notre santé mentale
alors je vais vous donner quelques
principes il y a plusieurs règles de
l'esprit mais je vous en donner trois et
je vous donner également des astuces
pour commencer à prendre soin de notre
santé mentale
alors la première règle c'est que
l'esprit verrouille sur les images et
les mots l'esprit répond aux images et
homos si je vous dis
n'essayez pas d'imaginer un éléphant
bleu avant que je finisse la phrase vous
l'avez vu les fonds bleus n'est-ce pas
c'est la capacité de pouvoir de votre
Esprit l'Esprit répond aux images et aux
mots
la deuxième chose c'est que l'esprit son
rôle c'est de faire exactement ce qu'il
pense que vous voulez qu'il fasse
et la manière dont il sait ce que vous
voulez qu'il fasse c'est par les images
par les mots par les pensées
donc il n'y a aucune pensée qui arrive
dans votre esprit et qu'il soit neutre
si je vous dis
médecin vous appelle et vous dit ah je
suis désolé de vous annoncer que telle
personne qui est proche il n'y a que n'a
que trois ou quatre jours à vivre vous
allez avoir une réaction physique
accélération du rythme cardiaque ou
accélération de la respiration
tremblements vous allez avoir une
réaction physique le monsieur au
téléphone il vous a pas vu il vous a pas
touché mais votre esprit a verrouillé
sur ces mots votre esprit a fait une
image a compris ce que ça voulait dire
il y a une réaction physique c'est le
pouvoir de votre mental
alors toutes les pensées qu'elles soient
négatives ou positives que vous rendez
compte ou pas ont un effet sur votre
physique de toutes les maladies qu'on a
mais on rentrera pas là-dedans et la
troisième chose c'est que l'esprit
apprend par répétition
à force de répéter une de ses pensées
les images et les mots à force de les
répéter elles s'encre de plus en plus et
ça devient une croyance
alors vu qu'on a dit tout ça
naturellement pour prendre soin de sa
santé mentale il va falloir se répéter
ce que l'on veut que l'esprit fasse et
puis voilà quoi fin de l'histoire et
pour guérir pour se porter mieux il va
falloir retirer de son esprit toutes les
croyances limitantes alors c'est quoi
une croyance limitante une croyance
limitante c'est pas nécessairement une
mauvaise croyance une croyance limitante
c'est une croyance qui n'est pas adaptée
par rapport à l'objectif que vous voulez
atteindre
donc j'ai reçu une fois une dame d'une
quarantaine d'années qui cherchait à
tomber enceinte elle n'y arrivait pas
séance d'hypnothérapie et on sait on a
réalisé que son esprit avait verrouillé
sur cette croyance que si je tombe
enceinte je vais être rejeté ces
dangereux alors la croyance venait du
fait que quand elle avait 12 ans sa
cousine du même âge était tombée
enceinte avait été chassé de la famille
on a pu entendu parler d'elle cette
croyance là à 12 ans c'est une croyance
magnifique hein nous on veut que nos
enfants croient ça
vraiment c'est une bonne croyance à 12
ans mais pour une femme qui a 40 ans qui
est dans un foyer qui est marié et qui
essaye d'avoir un enfant cette croyance
n'est plus adaptée mais à cause de cette
croyance limitante elle n'arrive pas à
accéder au bien-être qui lui permet
d'exploiter son potentiel alors ce qu'il
faut faire forcément j'allais
déconstruire cette croyance mais non à
12 ans on peut penser ça mais à 40 ans
on ne peut plus penser ça et elle est
remplacer ses croyances limitantes par
des croyances qui sont aidantes par
rapport à l'objectif que l'on veut
atteindre
du coup vous avez pratiquement déjà ma
première astuce
ce qu'il faut faire justement c'est
choisir ce dont on va nourrir notre
esprit
forcément dépenser positives pour
justement pouvoir manifester tout notre
potentiel
donc ça c'est la première astuce une des
deuxième une deuxième astuce
il faut changer
l'interprétation que l'on a des scènes
et des événements qui sont douloureux et
qui sont susceptibles de nous affecter
les scènes et les événements ne nous
affectent pas c'est l'interprétation que
l'on a des scènes et des événements qui
nous affectent
imaginez
je suis dans une salle d'attente bien
monsieur en face de moi qui me regarde
alors je peux être en mode
problème c'est qui c'est impoli là je
vais aller lui je vais aller lui dire
deux mots de fixer les gens voilà je
peux être plutôt en mode
ah je savais que la robe là c'était pas
pour moi vraiment si on peut m'appeler
rapidement je vais quitter ici et puis
être contracté baisser le visage et puis
sûrement il a remarqué que j'avais un
gros nez
et puis je peux être aussi dans un autre
mode
je m'appelle Rosine j'ai une robe rose
forcément ça sublime mon temps
j'ai cet effet là
en réalité cet homme là il peut être
juste aveugle
tout se remuage n'a rien à voir avec la
scène tout ce remue-ménage à avoir avec
ce que les croyances que j'ai les
pensées que j'ai les blessures sur
lesquelles on appuie donc
d'événements ne nous affectent pas c'est
l'interprétation qu'on leur donne et on
peut changer cette interprétation à tout
moment comme on a fait pour la dame qui
voulait être enceinte et c'est ce que je
veux vous inviter à faire pour les
événements et les scènes qui vous
affectent au quotidien mais également
celle de votre passé parce que souvent
on a été blessé abusé trahi abandonné
c'est vrai c'est douloureux mais on a
une double sentence parce que d'abord on
a été blessé et ensuite on reste enfermé
dans cette blessure on se met dans une
position de victime alors la position de
victime c'est pratique s'il y a rien à
faire mais ça veut dire qu'on attend
qu'un super héros que quelqu'un vienne
nous sauver et nous rendre justice ça
veut dire qu'on a remis à quelqu'un les
clés de notre succès de notre bonheur de
notre vie d'abord cette personne il y a
des chances qu'elle arrive jamais
et si elle arrive à des chances qu'elle
vienne abuser de nous elle a les clés de
notre bonheur alors non peut-être que ce
qui vous est arrivé n'était pas juste
peut-être que c'est pas votre faute mais
vous avez la responsabilité
de reprendre les clés de votre vie vous
avez la responsabilité d'écrire comment
l'histoire se termine vous avez
peut-être pas écrit le débit mais vous
pouvez décider comment s'écrit la fin
changer l'interprétation des scènes et
des événements qui sont douloureux pour
vous pour pouvoir avoir accès à ce
bien-être là pour pouvoir éviter de
rester dans les blessures et avoir accès
à l'exploitation de votre plein
potentiel
d'ailleurs pour revenir sur ma première
astuce
les pensées là il n'y a pas de pensée
neutre comme je vous ai dit donc ce que
vous êtes sûr dont vous allez nourrir
votre esprit si vous laissez de maigrir
et que vous êtes en mode je suis une
grosse vache bleue on a vu qu'on s'est
imaginé la pâte bleue votre esprit c'est
exactement de quoi il s'agit et il va
faire tout son possible mobiliser toutes
les ressources pour vous emmener vers
cet objectif donc faites attention aux
mots que vous dites après je suis
faites attention aux mots que vous
taperez je suis parce que les mots que
vous dites après je suis vous suivent ça
passe de penser à des croyances qui vont
déterminer la manière dont vous vous
comporter
et je vais vous donner une dernière
astuce
je pense que
la croyance la plus importante
la plus primordiale la plus cruciale
celle qu'elle a la capacité de
transformer toute votre vie
et je le dis avec beaucoup d'émotions
parce que ça transforme et la mienne
[Applaudissements]
alors
cette croyance là
c'est que ce que vous êtes suffisant
ce que vous êtes est suffisant vous êtes
parfait tel que vous êtes et il y en a
dans sa iris le poil quand je dis vous
êtes parfait tel que vous êtes il faut
vous acceptez mais on sait ce que
certains sont capables de faire pour
avoir le dernier iPhone ou le dernier
Samsung et pourtant en allant acheter ce
téléphone on sait que l'année prochaine
il y aura un autre téléphone qui sera
mieux
en allant acheter ce téléphone on sait
que dans un mois dans deux mois ils vont
perpétuellement nous demander de faire
des mises à jour on sait que la version
qu'on a n'est pas une version finale
qu'il y aura mieux encore mais on
accepte ce téléphone on est attaché à ce
téléphone et pourquoi lorsqu'il s'agit
de nous il faudrait qu'on soit parfait
avant de s'accepter avant de s'aimer
farouchement
est-ce qu'on peut faire preuve de la
même indulgence de la même miséricorde
qu'à nos téléphones
on est arrivé sur cette planète à
travers nos parents mais c'est Dieu qui
nous voulait ici
ce qui veut dire que nos circonstances
notre réalité peu importe la vérité
c'est qu'on compte qu'on a notre place
qu'on est important la vérité c'est
qu'on est parfait tel qu'on est et qu'il
faut s'accepter tel qu'on est et c'est
ce qui va ouvrir la porte
merci
et du coup c'est ce qui va ouvrir la
porte comme je disais à l'exploitation
de son plein potentiel et du coup la vie
que vous désirez le bonheur pour lequel
vous avez été prédestiné et disponible
pour vous aujourd'hui et comme disait ma
maman on ne fait pas de brouillon de vie
alors osé aller le décrocher merci